malley was two and two with a 3.59 era a
season ago
he pitched against the cardinals three
times and did not do well
the matter is paul goldschmidt who had a
heck of an opener knots the sign and
deals the payoff
swing and a miss struck him out it
wasn't a strike it was down and away
from goldschmidt
but he went after it and maui has his
first strikeout of the afternoon
on the cardinal side they go with their
hottest pitcher in spring training adam
wainwright was outstanding
wainwright is in his 17th season in the
big leagues
and now joey vado he had a hit on
thursday finished one for five with an
rbi
here's a swing and a drive left center
field on the run a leaping catch by
carlson
votto has denied extra bases by the
cardinal center fielder
young number 11 on the blue uniform for
the cardinals
3-2 pitch and a young hits head out to
deep left
at the wall gone
long home run for the cardinals
shortstop
and for paul de young his first of 20-21
one-nothing st louis
[Applause]
and now tucker barnhart a chance at the
plate
here's a high fly ball pretty well hit
to right center field williams back
gone home run tucker barnhart
reds lead 2-1 tucker barnhart
he's in the home run column two down for
a eugenio
suarez hard ground ball
backhand smother no play
winker scores castellanos to third base
knock rbi
a eugenio suarez and it's 3-1 rings
and mike mustakis digs in curveball
off the end of the bat that's a base hit
into left field a run will score
quickly around second suarez and he puts
on the breaks and i mean
right now o'neill quickly to that
baseball and that is the fourth run
here in the inning on a q shot down the
third base line for the moose
base is loaded for tyler naquin
1-1 on the ground sharp
past the dive of edmund base hit suarez
scores
mustaches scores indiana third a two-run
base knock
for tyler naked and they have blown it
wide open
with a six-run third in it
6-1 cincinnati that's our score top of
the fourth inning paul de young
and the cardinals will try to figure out
tyler malley in fact paul the only one
who has figured him out so far he hit a
home run in the second inning he's going
to lead things off
shadows starting to creep more onto the
field now covering first base and
the right fielder swaying at a hard hit
the left field did he do
it again back to the track and it's gone
another home run for paul deyoung and
the cardinals now trail
six to two ali lined to first his first
time up
3-2 pitch is hit to the right side and
tommy edmond
dies for it makes the play and throws
from his knees and they got him
nick castellanos ground out single run
scored
shift is on against him oh the first
pitch drills him
castillanos gives a stare and he'll be
granted first base
and he and yadier molina are talking at
home plate molina gives him a little pat
on the back
as if to say all good no ill intent
there
yachty keeping the peace out there
explaining what happened
offering the ball right on back to
woodford
i love the swag that castellanos has
the batter is mike moustakis first pitch
away squirts loose castigato storms
the shovel he say and castellanos right
in the face
of woodford and now the fish is empty
here we go the cardinals and reds mixing
it up
this divisional rivalry game castellanos
took exception to getting hit by a pitch
and woodford being held back by his
teammates as he repeatedly points at
castellanos
now the bullpens emerge
a lot of pushing and shoving right now
yada year molina
trying to calm everybody down at least
there's two separate
piles now everyone spilling out enjoying
thankfully seemingly no punches thrown
yet but
the emotions continue to ratchet but
just a lot of pushing and shoving right
now and it looks like cooler heads are
prevailing
the crowd all stands this is what you
get when you get these two clubs
together
castillanos had offered to the baseball
back to woodford
when he was hit two out spaces empty
and now some more chirping out on the
field in the outfield
they're converging again
both teams are spilling back out and
this is going into the outfield grass
remember two days ago that nick
castellanos ripped a home run
and he worked it a little skip to my lou
right there but you know what
i don't think really anyone takes
exception to that anymore
woodford's pitch way high and he walks
mustaches molina barely snared that one
and now jonathan india is the batter
base is loaded two down
one two i got a piece of molina's hand
it got a piece of india that's gonna
mean a run
eight to two on dylan carlson
carlson's day so far ground out and a
strikeout swinging
the pitch carlson swings and he lines it
to left field
and he goes off aquino's glove coming
around third base and
scoring nolan arenado an e7
and the cardinals get a run here in the
sixth inning
well miller will deal with aristides
aquino leading things off here in the
bottom of the sixth inning keno batting
in the spot previously occupied by nick
castianos who was ejected for the first
time in his career
and aquino launches one left field hit a
ton in deep
way back there it is gone rsd zucchino
with his first home run of the year
and the reds expand the lead 9-3
now it looks like there will be another
pinch hitter john nagowski
right-handed hitter a first baseman by
trade
the pitch and a ground ball up the
middle
backhanded by india quick throw got him
what a play by
jonathan india oh my goodness
carlson the three run homer the first
inning the first pitch that he saw of
this season
in game one the next delivery from
doolittle is
hit into right field by carlson and
that's backing up
the right fielder and naquin has it
tagging and scoring
is paul deyoung and the cardinals pick
up another run on the sacrifice fly rbi
dylan carlson
with runners advancing from second to
third and
molina staying at first base it's now
9-4 cincinnati
a hit and a run scored today for nolan
arnano
botto backing up it first and the 3-2
arenado with a drive out to deep left
and his first as a cardinal nolan
oronato
two run a homer number one with
st louis on a 3-2 pitch with two down in
the ninth inning
arenado has his second hit of the ball
game and the cardinals are down by
three with two gone what a day paul de
young's had he has scored three of the
cardinals six runs
in the air playable right naquin circles
in
and the reds win it